[Musique]
je me dufour si ça
je n'oublierai jamais cette histoire
mais je préfère toujours ma vache pas
faire et cette vie c'est créer un espace
de rigolade et un est un espace de
liberté où en fait les
les enfants vont pouvoir s'exprimer
aussi dans l'enceinte de l'établissement
ou sur scène alors une parole qui va
être cadré par la fonction de l'art beat
notamment avec l'accompagnement des
côtes
[Musique]
enfants
on va accueillir les élèves dès 18
heures à la mairie ils vont pouvoir se
rencontrer sans traîner un petit peu
s'échauffer découvrir la salle aussi
parce que c'est la première fois de
l'année qu'ils vont jouer dans une salle
aussi importante est vaste que la merise
[Musique]